[Music]
what's up guys michael here the locked
down messed up era of the pandemic has
made many of us reach for our television
comfort foods to stay sane for some that
means endless reruns of the west wing or
the office for others it's the nice core
antics of paddington bear or ted lasso
anything that allows us to disappear
into a gentler more optimistic world you
know i think that
if you care about someone
and you got a little love in your heart
there ain't nothing you can't get
through together you know what i'm
saying however we're also way too messed
up as a species to deal in a totally
wholesome way which may explain why the
last two years have also been in
absolute boom time for horror that's
when i start to buy my halloween stuff
what am i not supposed to buy my
halloween stuff really we've seen the
continued resurrection of classics like
halloween modern reimaginings of the
invisible man and viral sensations like
squid game clearly we can't help but
dive into the most nightmarish fiction
even as the real world feels something
like a horror movie of its own
now for those of us who like me
absolutely do not partake in spooky
content this seems like a masochistic
response but as i've been surprised to
learn it's actually a tried and true way
to respond to trauma on both a personal
and societal scale allow me to explain
in this wisecrack edition why we watch
horror in horrible times and spoiler
alert uh scary movies are scary uh
sometimes people die in them and ghost
now by march of 2020 the pandemic had
taken a hold over much of the world
entire countries were brought to a
standstill streets were emptied and
hospitals were overrun with a few
notable exceptions nobody seemed to have
much of a handle on the situation and in
the midst of this waking nightmare in
which every day seemed to bring some
fresh hell contagion became the most
watched film in the u.s that's right
after spending our days terrified of a
pandemic tearing our world apart we
decided to spend the evening relaxing in
front of a movie about a pandemic
tearing our world apart she's
overreacting right
not really and stop touching your face
and sure steven soderbergh simply does
not miss and we should exalt him even in
times of national tragedy but it's still
fascinating that we collectively chose
to spend our free time freaking out
about death germs rather than enjoying
say the relaxing charms of oceans 11 or
the gyrating delights of magic mike but
if we take a quick glance back across
the history of horror cinema it's
actually not that unusual in fact the
genre's most fertile periods have been
born out of the most tumultuous and
often straight-up terrifying of times
indeed you can chase that trend all the
way back to the early days of horror
cinema itself see american horror films
emerged in full force at the start of
the 1930s in the midst of the great
depression 1930 through 1934 would later
be known as the golden age of horror at
a time when everyone was flat broke what
little catch they had went straight into
the coffers of universal pictures a fair
trade for a few hours being petrified by
films like dracula and frankenstein we
belong
the former as film scholar robert
prechter notes was a fitting allegory
for the perceived fear of the day that
the aristocrat was sucking the blood of
the common people over the next few
years universal followed those up with
classics like the invisible man bride of
frankenstein and the mummy all of which
were smash hits that's right they made a
mummy film without brendan frazier in it
and people still turned up
and of course other studios quickly
hopped on the burgeoning genre's
bandwagon with paramounts dr jekyll and
mr hyde making it serious bank similarly
rko's king kong became an absolute
monster of a monster movie horror films
of the time were according to film
scholar jon towson defined by their
gruesomeness and brutality as scholar
david j skaal puts it this was a time
when all of the promises of the roaring
twenties and the faith and progress in
science just crashed and burned he notes
the popularity of the mad scientist
figure as a stand-in for the experts and
eggheads who would fail to save the
economy as well as the image of
frankenstein as a stand-in for the
abandoned proletariat but curiously
midway through the 30s as the country
emerged from the depression the horror
boom quickly fizzled out that's in part
due to the more strict enforcement of
censorship via the haze production code
still there were almost no horror movies
made in the us between 1937 and 1938 and
few being made anywhere else either it
seems then that people's hunger for
horror was inspired at least in part by
the hardships they were facing outside
the theater and this isn't an isolated
example the 1970s was also an era marked
by anxiety and unrest at home americans
were dealing with energy crises economic
downturn and rising crime rates don't
even get us started on how this decade
is considered the golden age of serial
killers and from abroad they were being
beamed images of the savage violence and
incomprehensible terror which was the
vietnam war with all this weighing on
the collective consciousness the 70s
produced another wave of iconic horror
films which were hungrily devoured by
their audience movies like the
amityville horror and the exorcist
topped the box office for their
respective years popular horror films of
the time again reflected existing
societal anxieties as stephen king notes
in dance macabre his non-fiction book on
the horror genre the exorcist isn't just
about the devil rather it is a film
about explosive social change a finely
honed focusing point for that entire
youth explosion that took place in the
late 60s and early 70s similarly the new
york times notes how films like texas
chainsaw massacre and halloween had
something important in common they had
more to do with what was going on
outside the studio than inside it in
this way they expressed the same horrors
folks were seen unfold on the nightly
news and we've seen exactly the same
phenomenon occur in the last couple of
years while the box office as a whole
has been throttled by lockdowns you'll
still find the likes of the quiet place
2 the forever purge malignant and old
amongst recent top performers in fact in
2020 horror took home its biggest share
of the box office in modern history and
the series like fear street midnight
mass made major splashes plus squid game
unexpectedly became netflix's biggest
ever debut a reported 111 million
viewers tuned in they luxuriated in its
brutal commentary on economic inequality
and the deathly cutthroat competition of
global capitalism you can also check out
our recent video on squid games f
depiction of the modern debt crisis so
while it's highly debatable whether hard
times toughen us up they certainly seem
to make us horror fans so why are we
drawn to slashers and creature features
during such difficult times well the
answer might lie in how our brains
respond to these kinds of films that's
according to sally winston executive
director of the anxiety and stress
disorders institute of maryland she
explains that while watching horror
films your heart pumps and the
adrenaline flows and your attention
narrows in that's even though you know
that you're not really in danger behind
jane this basically means that we can
enjoy the rush of a good scare without
the distress it would cause in reality
and how much you enjoy this jolt seems
to depend heavily on how your brain is
wired rutgers professor of psychiatry
david zald suggests that some people
seem to be built without breaks on the
dopamine their brain releases allowing
them to experience a serious terror high
we also then get to ride a wave of
relief as we recover from each fight and
remember that we aren't actually in
danger this is a phenomenon known as
excitation transfer theory which
suggests that the heightened state one
stimuli puts us into also strengthens
the sensation that follows so basically
the higher a movie raises our heart rate
the more satisfying it is to feel it
coming back down all of this also speaks
to the idea of catharsis which we at
wisecrack talk about a lot catharsis a
term first coined by aristotle describes
the way art allows us to fully
experience emotions by proxy
expresses
modern man and all his self-pity anyway
this only explains why we enjoy horror
films in general not why we seek them
out in terms of real-life terror and the
answer to that might be that these
movies actually make us better able to
deal with fear in real life a finnish
study used a magnetic resonance image
scanner to monitor brain activity while
watching a horror movie they found that
as the movie builds tension the parts of
the brain involved in visual and
auditory perception become more active
as we scan the screen for potential
threats then the shock we have been
anticipating delivers that's when the
regions responsible for emotion
processing and threat evaluation fire up
those are the same sections you'd count
on when making a rapid high-stakes
decision like what to do when a dude
starts chasing you with a chainsaw
in effect horror movies can provide a
form of exposure therapy by putting us
in situations where we face our fears in
an environment of safety and control and
it's one in which we can push a button
and make it all go away a recent study
even found that people who suffer from
anxiety are paradoxically more likely to
be drawn to horror movies possibly for
this exact reason indeed extensive
research has found this process hugely
beneficial for people suffering from
anxiety ocd or ptsd it enables them to
experience control over and better
process their fears thus decreasing
anxiety so at a time where we all have
more reasons than usual to be
perpetually anxious it kind of makes
sense that we would dive into horror
films to prepare ourselves it could save
your life this idea was borne out by a
recent study from the university of
chicago it found that putting our brains
and bodies through hell voluntarily gets
them in perfect shape for a very
involuntary event like say a
[ __ ] plague measuring how a
range of american adults responded to
the pandemic researchers found that
those with a predilection for horror
flicks generally coped better they
displayed a higher degree of resilience
and found themselves more able to
continue enjoying life in spite of you
know
everything and this trend is continued
throughout the pandemic with a 2020
survey of now tv users finding that
horror fans were less daunted by the
prospect of an imminent second wave and
well
good for them and fans of pandemic
related and dystopian horror in
particular reportedly also felt more
prepared for the realities of the panini
after all these films provide them with
a few pieces of practical advice stock
up on essentials aim for the head etc
what's more unsettling sites like empty
supermarket shelves and deserted streets
likely didn't feel nearly as shocking to
connoisseurs of the genre as it turns
out even the end of the world is a lot
less scary the second or twentieth time
around but it's not just what horror
films do on an individual psychological
level it's the shared experience of
collectively watching and being haunted
by the same nightmares horror has always
been an immensely social genre one of
the reasons it performs so well at the
box office is that these are movies we
want to witness together even if it's
only to laugh a little at the person
who's screaming the loudest it's usually
me
watching something scary as part of an
audience taps into one of our most basic
human instincts to seek safety in
numbers viewing horror films in a group
provides us with an added layer of
reassurance if the little girl from the
ring pops out of the screen and tries to
snatch us maybe she'll grab someone
sitting in another row instead this
theory of horror movies bringing us
closer together was even bolstered by a
university of alberta study in 2009 in
it people in a control group who watched
the shining were more attracted to
messages of communal togetherness and
affiliation than the control group that
watched richard linklaters before
sunrise and that's really saying
something because who among us has not
dreamed of communal togetherness with
ethan hawk and or julie delphi
if you know what i mean
once you've sat together and watched
michael myers use a kitchen knife to
nail a full-grown human being to a wall
you've established a sense of community
even if that community disperses when
the credits start to roll i'll be right
back so the world still seems to be
crumbling around us but at least we have
freddy and jason and now the masked
crowd at the movie theater to help us
through the hardest times naturally
horror films will never be everyone's
idea of a fun friday night for some
people the anxiety induced by the scares
simply isn't worth the relief that comes
afterwards and if disney musicals or 90s
rom-coms are the bomb you need to make
it through this crazy world then go for
it but for all you adorable freaks who
love looking at blood and guts horror
might just be the psychological
equivalent of a weighted blanket
but what do you guys think will you be
spending halloween filling your eyeballs
with all the horror you can or does a
quiet night of great british baking show
sound more your speed let us know in the
comments big thanks as always to our
patrons for all your support check out
our podcast or i'll haunt your dreams
stab that subscribe button like it just
had sex in an 80 slasher movie and don't
forget to ring that bell as always
thanks for watching later
[Music]